hello welcome to the sensing left I'm
glad that the universe conspired to rely
on what was off-center the minute the
decision was made everything has been
suits beating incredibly high octane if
he had to go go go
[Music]
funnier last season
our show builds bridges and powers
people we all bleed when woke up we all
have the same thoughts we all feel grief
and love it's always been about that
common humanity it's a show that is for
every we are surrounded by the best
quality of human beings that we could
have it's been beautiful every it's a
real joint every set location they're
there five dozen it was nuts I've never
seen anything like that it's because of
the show from Brazil they're like really
crazy about a really professional man we
also get to be a part of that and see
them and listen to these stories and
possibly use that energy while filming
all those people in every country they
are our extended cluster it just feels
like a big bowl of love my goodness what
a journey
now I'm proud to be a part of this happy
that we can give them an end that was
satisfied
you
you